I
it's a pleasure of mine to introduce
Andy Miller he's one of the maintainer
Xandra lease managers of psychic learn
the premier machine learning package in
Python also Andy works for for amazon so
he's been there for I think a year now
and then he's going to be talking to us
about commodity machine learning thanks
for that introduction and thanks
everybody for coming so early in the
morning I heard was long night so I want
to talk about commodity machine learning
and what I mean by this is that I think
machine learning should be easy and
should be for everybody to use and I
think we're nearly there so in
particular I want you to use machine
learning I think whatever your
application is whatever your business is
basically everybody can profit from
using machine learning and we're really
at a stage where you can simply do this
even without a lot of expert knowledge
so I know probably most of you are
familiar with like basic machine
learning concepts but I still want to
repeat a little bit on what machine
learning can do for you so oh the most
basic and most classical machine
learning task is classification where
you have some data points and you want
to assign a class for example in spam
detection you're given some emails and
you want to say are a spam or are they
ham so this is a binary classification
tasks you're getting a data point you
want to say spam or ham there's two
closets another classification task
that's used quite a lot is click through
prediction or CTR where people are shown
ads like here in facebook and you want
to predictable user click on this ad or
not this is a bit more tricky than
standard classification because you're
usually interested in how likely is it
that a user will click course actually
clicking happens only and point zero
percent of 1.01 percent of the time or
something so you can actually predict
when it happens but you can estimate
probability for that
so the second really big fuel machine
learning that's used a lot in practice
as recommendations so for example here
you can see that Amazon Amazon was first
to actually do this a lot so there's
several recommendation systems going on
here in the bottom you can see customers
who bought this also about that
recommendations drive a lot off what you
see in social sides you see on facebook
on twitter and if you listen to last.fm
or Spotify all of these user
recommendations and maybe as a last
application here there is ranking which
means giving a search query give the
most relevant results for example if you
do web search or something like that or
even just searching within a page
usually the way it is done is use
something like elastic search to get a
tenth of thousands of candidate hits so
retrieve these documents and then do
machine learning approach on top of that
to re-rank and say get a top ten they're
really relevant for the query and so as
I said fine machine learning is already
quite easy so I think with the tools out
there particular wish I could learn it's
really easy and a lot of people can use
it but I feel like it should still be
easier to use and I want to talk about
what i think is still missing and what
we already achieved so I guess you're
all familiar with the scientific Python
stack which is my favorite tool for
doing machine learning and hopefully
yours too and particularly I want to
highlight three libraries or three
projects that drove the option of
machine learning the first one is the
ipython notebook which makes data
exploration much more easy much more
interactive it also takes away a lot of
the fear of programming get some
analytics people might have because you
don't need to open an IDE or anything
like that
can just work in your browser and you
get results directly and you can
visualize the second one is pandas which
gives you all the tools and
functionality you need to analyze your
data to visualize your data to work with
like unclean datasets in particular to
work with dates and to do all the
crunching that you need to do before you
can actually start with machine learning
and last but not least obviously so I
could learn and I want to talk a bit
more about why things I could learn has
been successful so I mean it so first I
want to say well it is indeed successful
so here are some of the companies that
admit to using it and I'm pretty sure
there's a lot more companies that
actually do use it so I heard a couple
of talks where their other companies
using it that are here so if you're
using cycle own and your tonneau
testimonial site send us a testimonial
because it really helps us get sponsors
and get it granted university which
helps us improve software and apart from
using industry there's also yeah 500 or
600 research paper that you scikit-learn
and that again that other ones that
actually say they're using us probably
twice as much and so one of the reasons
I thinks I could learn some was so
successful or is so successful is it is
pretty simple and has a very
straightforward interface so to solve a
classification tasks basically this is
what you have to do it's four lines of
Python code I think everybody can do
that so you get your model from so I
could learn you instantiate your model
you call fit to actually learn the model
so machine learning is actually does one
line so I don't think it can get much
easier than that and predict to apply
your model obviously this is not the
whole story there are things like
setting the parameters for the model to
model selection doing pre-processing for
the data but the core of machine
learning is really these couple of lines
and I think this is one of the success
of 12 reasons course I could learn
success and so I mentioned spam
filtering before so actually to build a
fully functional spam classifier this is
what you have to do three lines of
imports and three lines of actual code
so for a super bowlea the Senators
classifier or the classical classifier
for spam classification is naive base
and so we import that the second line
imports the current vector Iser which I
described my tutorial or 12 days ago
what it does is basically it transforms
the text data of the email to a matrix
representation so that the machine
learning algorithms can work with it and
so make pipeline just puts these two
together so first you preprocess your
text data and make it into a matrix
using count vector riser and on top of
that you learn a knife based classifier
and this gives you a fully functional
spam classifier given you have some
label data the second reason where I
think a secular was successful was
because there's really a wide array of
algorithms I don't want to go through
these but a lot of people said just if
you think pick any machine learning
model the chance yet since I could learn
is pretty high so actually we try to
have all models that are in elements of
statistical learning one of the major
books in machine learning and also that
are in pattern recognition of machine
learning I'd be shocked and I think
we're nearly there there's maybe two
models missing from the classical ones
and I think the third and also very
important factor for a success of cycle
urn was this so we did the Apollo I
think like a year ago on what people
think about so I could learn what I
think is bad what is good and this was a
kind of typical answer or maybe a bit of
a hyperbole so someone said thus I could
learn tutorial documentation so good one
doesn't need a textbook anymore to learn
a new machine learning method so I might
so as I said it might be a bit of a
hyper balls I totally encouraged you to
read as much machine learning textbooks
as you can
but still I think it's quite telling
that people use the documentation this
way and I've seen documentation we
referenced outside of psychic learn
context or just in general machine
learning discussions someone asked how
do you do X how do you do y how does
this algorithm work and people reference
site in the second learn documentation
and not Wikipedia so I think we can feel
pretty good about that so I think it was
enough putting ourselves on the back so
yeah but this is not enough so we have
good documentation we have a good
library that people can use that there's
still areas where machine learning in
Python or machinery in general is
lacking I feel and the way I think about
is so long these two axes as shown here
one is the amount of data that we can
actually process so the data set size
and the other one is the amount of
automation that we have or on the other
hand the amount of expertise that is
needed so Italy I want to be everybody
to use machine learning no matter what
their background is and so I want to
label these axes just a little bit so
for data set size I think there's three
main categories are interesting so small
data is the one that fits into ram for
me then there's like a middle ground
where you can process data on a single
machine but doesn't fit into Rama
anymore just often called out of car
learning and then there's infinite
scalability which is what i call
basically har du or spark or you have
something on the cluster in HDFS and you
can always buy more machines and then
and in the axis of automation well on
the one hand you have libraries which
are like scikit-learn or pandas which
you can use to make predictions but you
basically you have to roll your own
program every time so you have a large
array of functionality but you
definitely need to code to make anything
out of it and the other end of the
spectrum would be one click solution
which says just like here's my data
do machine learning and so and this is
how I actually see what's out there at
the moment so the Python ecosystem is
mostly in this lower left corner where
for example panel since I could learn
both relief they need you to code pandas
really provides kind of very convenient
but sort of low-level functionalities I
could learn tracts away bit more from
the user but they both basically work on
a single machine there are some tools
that work on more data but not really
for machine learning in Python and so
this really mostly work on around
there's there's very little automation
there's a project called scowl or
scikit-learn library which makes it
easier to run experiments but it's still
quite manual and it doesn't necessarily
right you need you to write programs but
it's not very flexible yet then there's
like it's all on the side which is
basically cloud computing or machine
learning on the cloud and so we have
blazed there to bottom which is really
sort of the only thing that is really in
this in the Python space completely
which is a new project by continuum it's
still I would say in early phases and
actually yeah I think it's a great
direction but definitely work in
progress and also it's more like on the
level of pandas so the idea there is to
have a distributed data frame basically
so it doesn't give you any machine
learning tools it just gives you just
okay it's a very hard task so it just
gives you distributed just presentation
of your data then there's so one of the
most promising project at the moment i
think is spark together with ml lip so i
spark as a distributed in memory
framework for parallel data processing
so this is actually what blazes now
built on and an ellipse machine learning
library so in a way this is the same
level of abstraction that you have in
cyclic learned you have a library that
gives you
machine learning functions you can apply
these functions to do your machine
learning it has the great advantage that
it can work in a burrow data sets so I
think this is a will be a very very
useful tool in the future however it's
not really there yet and also it's Scala
which is maybe not that nice for us I
don't know so I think we should think
about how can we make put path more on
this space so even if we would have
blazed we still would not be where mlms
at a moment and then going to more
automation there's these more or less
commercial products so there's a zoo ml
which was recently Oh announced by a
Microsoft as a cloud machine learning
solution so this gets a way of the sort
of hassle of installing your own cloud
but in the end it's all right so all so
just provides the library so you have to
roll your own solution still then
there's data bricks so they released a
very cool solution quite recently if you
have you should look at their sparks I'm
at keynote if you happens at them so
they actually have a solution that
includes both the Python front end and a
scallop front end and that's cloud
computing and very amazing
visualizations the main downside there
so this is all built on spark and ml
looped remain downside there is that as
a company it's completely closed source
so basically we cannot use it and even
their beta is closed and maybe they're
so there's there's there's way more
setups in the space but I just picked
out like these two and reserved ml
because I think they're kind of
interesting from there from how they
approach the problem then there's
friction i/o which I maybe should have
put more on top they are actually an
open-source company so they built an
open source product that detect some of
the verticals today give your library to
build your own machine learning
solutions that a give you a framework
where you can do things like
recommendation or ranking or
classification so this is much closer to
the one click solution they give you
something that you can directly
integrate into the web application yeah
but so but this is good but actually
they don't have any price and support at
the moment I think and as orem I will
probably have priced support to
hopefully quite soon but at the moment
there's nothing there so yeah so you can
see we're very good at a lower left
there's something happening in the lower
right but the rest is pretty empty so
now you could say well you argued that
we should actually be like we should
have something very automatic that it's
infinitely scalable so you want to be at
the top right and so we're in the top
bottom left so maybe we should just
throw out all so I could learn and
pandas and not use it anymore and work
on something like do scala but obviously
that's not what i want to say so i would
argue that it's important to have sort
of something in all four corners of this
diagram to have some tools in for each
of these applications and that's what i
want to talk about next so first i think
a lot of people approach me saying hey
can you do psych and learn and hadoop or
spa or something like that and usually
my answer is so why would you want to do
that because in ninety nine percent of
the cases a single machine is enough and
yeah probably some people don't believe
this but I want to explain to you why so
the first reason why I think the single
machine is enough is curse this is sort
of the single machine i usually used as
a single machine at you should use if
you have a bit more data so that's like
send that you see to 32 cores 256
gigabyte of ram this is way cheaper than
hiring three data scientists set up your
Hadoop cluster don't set up a Hadoop
cluster if it data fits on this machine
you can just get to some easy to or I
don't care you can get this also from
zoar or something like that and you can
just run psych and learn or even our or
whatever you want on this and will be
super fast super responsively super easy
to install and really do you really have
that much data I
don't know that many companies that have
more than 250 gigabyte of interesting
data and the other reason why I think
this is the case or why I think people
don't have that much data is so I'm
talking about machine learning I'm not
actually talking about big data there's
a big difference for me so big data is
usually very unstructured data like
locks or Twitter posts but I'll show at
the beginning usually and if you're
doing machine learning you're mostly
doing supervised learning and it's
supervised learning if your data and
also you have a label that you want to
predict like four emails at spam or not
spam or will a user click the add or not
to click yet and this is very very
structured data and in the huge amount
of locks that you may be gathered about
your users most of the data will not
have this kind of structure that but
this is really what is very valuable
having these label samples because they
allow you to predict something for the
future if you're lucky you can maybe
have this for from the past so for these
clicks for example you can gather from
the past whether someone clicked on
something or not and I or if you want to
do stock prediction you know how to stop
behaved in the past and you can try to
learn how this was how does will be in
the future but if you do spam detection
you have no idea whether an email was
spam or not unless a human said there's
a spam or this is not spam if you do
fraud detection you do sentiment
analysis for a tweet no you can't really
find out after Twitter sent whether it
was happy or sad or angry or neutral a
human has to go in and label it as such
so for the data to be really useful and
valuable and so after you do that I
really doubt that you still have like
two billion bit data points so this is
why I think that for most people just
get a big single box and you'll be very
happy and much happier than setting up
some Hadoop cluster so this is the
reason why I think being on a lower half
of the
or so you're on the left half of my pot
is a good idea for most people and they
also think being sort of on the lower
half of the plots so doing something
that is not as automatic it's a good
idea because we actually we do need it
openbox methods where you can go in and
do analysis by hand so this actually
probably what most people do here is
they dig through the data use pandas
they look what are the important
features how do I have to clean this up
and for this you really need is open box
methods you need to try out different
classifiers different pre-processing and
so to really get most of the most of
your data you have to do this so there's
probably no way around it so I think
probably people will agree that it's
important to have open box methods that
allow you to really get deep impacts
into your data on the other hand I think
we also need black box methods and this
is something that we haven't really done
so far so one of the reasons why I think
we need black box methods is that I
don't know if you saw this this kind of
a geek chart that I made a while ago on
how I think I should you should do
machine learning actually on how i think
i should do machine learning helps you
sort of he loots i could learn and you
want to do a regression regression
classification or clustering so that
what kind of methods i would use and the
sad thing is that actually i do that so
if I someone gives me at HSN and I go
through like is this text this is not
text how many data points do I have will
I use a linear classifier or non-linear
one can I do nearest neighbors and so if
i can write down this charge then i can
make this automatic right so often i
spend like I don't know a day two days
or a week just trying out all cycle
learn on a classification problem or on
a regression problem and I feel like I
shouldn't be doing this I actually have
better things to do and so if i can
write down this chart i think we can
automate this and I think a lot more
effort should go into this and so
basically the program should
automatically try
whatever i will try first and then after
that i opened the box and looking what
are important features what does the
data mean but before that i would just
throw the kitchen sink at it and just
like deuce i could learn from me and so
that's what how I wanted to look so
basically when someone gets me a new
data set I put in my data SI predict and
then i'll give me a dashboard and say
like hey i tried all these like a
cuddler models and i tried all these
models and these are the important
features this is what worked this is
what didn't work and then once i have
that then i can go in and dig deeper but
really the machine should need me for to
do that and currently i have to do all
of this manually wish it I think it's
kind of a bit of a waste of my time and
the good news is there's actually tools
out there to do this already at least to
some degree this is called automatic
machine learning or hyper parameter
optimization this was particularly
popular and the deep learning community
because neural nets are hard to train
and have like billions of parameters
though they have doing summer parameters
but tens of hyperparameters so it's very
hard to tune in my hand and there's for
example these three projects that came
out of it or these are more research
projects to select architectures for
live learning models but it can be more
widely applied to select machine
learning models and so because I think
they're cool I just end because someone
asked me about it I put in this slide to
explain how they work so they use this
framework of Beijing optimization so I
stole the slide from some tutorial of
none that if writers and obviously this
is this is what's called global
optimizations we have a pretty
unstructured search space and you want
to find the optimum this is an np-hard
problem so all bets are off but this
works good well in practice so the idea
here is imagined you only have one
parameter do you want to adjust like the
regularization or something like that
and that's the depicted on the x-axis
yeah see a pointer probably not
branch okay so let's say you try two
points that you saw like two things of
the parameter at the top so you have
these two black dots label owns
observation and there's a sort of your
tritus parameter you get as a result you
try to sell the parameter and you got
this results what you do now is to fit
some some probabilistic model to
regression model videos for example a
Gaussian process so this Gaussian
process will give you the solid black
line here which has the mean and in this
purple kind of cloud thing as the
variance so they were Gaussian process
will think well this is where this
function is whereas the dashed line is
the true function and you want to find
the optimum office true function so the
maximum which is sort of somewhere on
the right and so now you want to say
what's the next model that I should try
so what's the next parameter of them or
what's the next parameter of the model
that I should try and the whities work
is they compute this acquisition
function to seeing green on the bottom
and wherever the maximum of this
acquisition function is this is where
were you you'll try you'll try and pair
meet your next so the idea is that to
evaluate this dashed line means training
a model this is super expensive you have
to my if you're unlucky you have to
start up your hairdo cluster and earn
some big MapReduce job or you have to
try and if I can learn it's not that
slow and but if I lighting this green
function is very simple because this is
just computed from the Boston process
and you've hit it and the idea is this
this green function combines both where
do you think the function is very high
and also very very uncertain so at right
not the function is very high but you're
also very certain so you want won't try
this point again but around it so this
is the highest point you have and around
the DL circuitry spreads and it's
probably also going to be high around as
high point so this is why the green
curve is pretty high around this point
[ __ ] tried and it was good so it will
find a maximum of the green curve and
try out this parameter next then you get
a new observation and then you refit
your gaussian process you get a new
uncertainty and you mean function you
can recompute your requisition function
you get a maximum of that one and Gavin
we point to try out and then at some
point if you do this long enough you'll
have somewhere where to meet the maximum
at UF the acquisition function is at a
place where you're very certain what the
function is then you're done so this is
a very neat way to do this global
optimization to search over models and
work with the function it's very
expensive to compute like training whole
model and we should really do more of
this I think yeah so anyhow let's go
back to my diagram and so I said that I
think most of the time we really don't
need more than one off machine so
actually even at amazon i had no
application that didn't fit on this one
box and or give me a bad one but
basically all of them fit on the one box
i still i mean sometimes you need to
scale beyond a single machine so for
example we have the thing like the
kindle that you probably know and we
have books on it and sometimes you try
to do learn a language model for example
and so what do we take as a kapre we
take all the books that are on the
kindle so that don't fit on a single
machine and in particular if you want to
run a model on this like this is a lot
of data and so you actually want to
distribute this so there are cases where
you want to distribute or if your
Twitter and you want to do analysis all
the tweets that come in at once and do
spam detection on them probably you also
need more than one machine but I think
this is really the rare case so yeah so
let's get back to my diagram so I think
as I said in the lower right lower left
corner we're pretty good off and on the
right hands oh so
is what I think about it so I think
we're pretty good up in left hand corner
I don't want to say like this is done
and we don't need any more work but I
think we were in a pretty good situation
on the right hand side we have some
interesting ideas some good developments
unfortunately I feel like python is not
as far as scala there and also the open
source solutions are really lacking
behind the commercial solutions and yeah
I really put my hopes on blaze and
somewhat on ml lip and let's see where
it goes but actually I think we should
focus more on a cup of the chart so
having something scalable is great but
for most of us it's not as important
it's more important to have something
working quickly and was less work so
that we can spend on our time for to
actually design better models and do
more meaningful work instead of trying
out so I don't know about you but I try
out too much and I think we should we
need to automate this more and this is
why i think we should really focus on
the top of the chart where we are not
really happy yet okay i think i'm a bit
too fast but that it was all I had for
today thanks
okay thank you very much for that
awesome keynote so now let's take some
questions from the audience so yeah
there's a question not really hi so you
said you want to push machine learning
more as the top of the chart to the one
click solution space yeah I was
wondering that quite a lot of the quite
a lot of the work actually calls into
cleaning the data and selecting what you
feed into the machine learning method
and then once you've done that you can
then try out a thousand different
solutions and see what comes out but how
do you think cleaning the data is that
something that could be automated at
least partially I think so yeah I think
cleaning the data is also very important
and this is definitely a step where
there's a lot of manual work going into
it but so I think you can kind of
automate it but I think it will be
easier to just try to work with the
unclean data and see what comes out or
like cleared up roughly automatically
and see what comes out then afterwards
you can see what working what didn't
work so that would be my approach at a
moment I'm much it's it's a very hard
problem to do this and actually so I'm
more comfortable in automating machine
learning outta making data cleanup maybe
because I feel this is easier any more
questions all right yes so I was just
the machine has a much more important
then he pacified exam so in addition to
solve the days I mean do you think that
closely I'm automatically yeah so
there's nothing else I can learn for
that yet there's I think much too few
automations I could learn there is a
ways to automatically generate features
I wouldn't say so much for computer
vision in computer vision I think really
at the moment we're at a point where we
should try more deep learning and
confidence because that really worked
quite well at the moment yeah it's
probably a final answer but I don't
think we can automatically generate like
new computer vision feature so easily I
mean you could try out a battery say
like do sift freak whatever LBP and try
to select these so if you know you have
these then you could do automatic
feature selection actually yeah some
people use these patient optimization to
a friend of mine uses to do feature
selection that you would have to specify
sort of the beginning what kind of
things you want to search over right so
answer your question so I really enjoyed
your talk about commodity machine
learning do you believe that machine
learning is becoming a commodity and
then linked those questions that data
science is going to become data
processing science instead of actual
machine learning because if it's a
commodity then it's just like preparing
the data and then press play on your ml
service and and that's it is becoming a
commodity I hope so at least partially
so a lot of the problems that have
actually interesting structure and you
will not be able to capture the end like
the structure of the problem using
something very automated but from my
experience of an industry and what I
when I talk to people of people use
binary classification because it gives
them a good enough solution for the
problem and so I don't want to spend
time designing diner binary classifiers
and I think this will definitely become
a commodity I'd actually like to ask a
question so sort of perhaps one of the
hurdles and turning machine learning
into sort of something that is commodity
is actually sort of deeply understanding
the methods so like deeply understanding
sort of the mathematics behind each one
of the methods and not just sort of
blindly sort of applying them and seeing
what which one works best do you think
there's a there's a way to tackle this
so kind of I mean in a way I feel you
don't actually need to understand them
so so if you go this is actually I mean
okay I would kind of say that I
understand them like a little bit but
actually the rules that I use that very
simple so five many data points that use
SGD and I I know I can't use car lots
and it's actually the way I make a
decision as a very simple decision tree
is actually very much like this if I
know the daycare sparse I'm not going to
use a forest and so I mean I don't need
to know like how the Gini index is
computed to know if the four is going to
work or some or not so I mean so this
obviously you will do much better than
what this chart can do or what an
automated method can do but it will get
you like ninety percent of the way I
think that's my opinion at least thank
you more questions yeah in front maybe
you could also try to learn this chart
if you if you have a lot of different
machine learning tasks and love
different data sets that one also makes
sense and maybe at amazon um you have
access to that many different resources
and approaches so yeah but then I can't
publish it yeah actually I mean there's
so this one here hyper up in the middle
stand by James Burke striding actually
he kind of worked on things like that
where you like learn about sets of
problems and when to use which
that more than optimization sense it at
it but it's yeah it's certainly possible
and it's something we should do more
yeah if a question regarding the
approach to the optometric automatic
hyper parameter optimization so you
presented Beijing optimization as basic
method for doing that but you didn't
talk a lot about the matrix of the
objective function to be used so I guess
you could just simply use
cross-validated accuracy or so but then
there would be the risk of like
overfitting your your data your
validation data so what would you be
approached you would lie to that is so
you're asking if I've well I'm
overfitting my like validation data like
if you apply like tons of different
algorithms with many different I mean
like many parameters to be fit
hyperparameters and like you have a huge
problem and there would be like a huge
potential to overfit your validation
data then yeah I mean you can regular
rice the optimization method and
obviously you should in the end have
additional test set to validate what you
found and there's probably I mean
there's no other way about them if you
want to optimize over a lot of
parameters then you need to have the
data but on the other hand if I do this
now I'll also over fit so it doesn't
really matter if I do it manually or
automatically may be automatically can
try a couple of more models but even
manually I would try a lot of models and
so probably we all do this over fitting
right now but I nurse no can answer for
that
this is not really a question is more
like a comment so we've seen that okay
machine learning sometimes you can
change the methods but to get more or
less the same results as in logistic
regression linear kernel machine gives
more or less the same results for some
problems so the key is actually all the
feature that you are creating so if you
are actually going to make like this
easily to use just a click a button to
test everything maybe you also need to
give like results like Eddie's what's
working and what's not working like
because when i get a result I don't
compare with a second 1i second point
one percent better so it's a better
machine learning or array i made an
improvement i need to understand what
the actual the algorithm is returning I
mean what feature did you use I mean
usually just go check the coefficients
and see for specific examples what what
actually finding so this way of looking
into the machine I mean to the actual
model classifier is maybe more important
probably like giving a simple return
like I mean okay this is your model this
is your results and this is what I think
it's doing somehow I mean this is what
weeks working so I totally agree i think
and it's very d id reset after my
machine spit something out I have to so
to get a good result I have to go in and
so I just want to sort of let's say I
did a feature I designed a new feature
and so I want to test if this is good I
don't want to go through all the week of
trying out all models and if the feature
improves on any of the models so
actually I was shown just want to click
on my black box again and say it's this
feature good is there model where the
teacher will now be important and so
definitely I want it to be automatic but
I also want to be able to open up the
box and see what's happening okay any
more questions okay so if there's no
more ah there's one more question
basically the same scene we attached on
upon earlier but and aren't you afraid
that you just handle users who are not
well aware how in machine learning works
once the dangers of overfitting we are
our what's check the dangers of chosing
the wrong model are to just hand them a
bigger gun to choose themselves in the
foot so I'm thinking about the X require
to basically get asked whether boss they
need to deliver our model by the end of
days the end of business then well just
hectically import something from actual
I'm let's start out a multi-modal on it
get some promising looking results and
noises so I sings out um say this
impression is Samson becomes a commodity
it's easy to understand and easy to do
and I think it will be easy to do but
not necessarily easy to understand yes
it will but I don't think it's necessary
for everybody to easy understand so you
say I'm giving people bigger gun to
shoot themselves in the foot but I would
disagree we curse so currently they
might like just pick any model at random
and put any very dirty data in that and
so then they will get some sort of
results and maybe they don't do correct
cross-validation and maybe they over fit
completely with their parameters because
they don't do any cross-validation at
all or they just training their whole
test set but if this process is more
automated actually the people who know
more about the models can help build a
process that prevents them from shooting
themselves in the foot so I can build it
in a way that it will always do cross
validation
okay so let's thank Andy once again
you
you